[Music]
it was wrong wasn't it uh what what
but FAO is fine okay
Miriam from originally canceled and you
asked a question
Eloise you guys know do invitation as
non-muslims and we have preservation
preservation is for our Muslim young I
didn't really think the question if you
properly in it but it's something along
the lines of a free will basically I
didn't really quite understand it
basically that save God makes year how's
the UFO that you like if you know man is
a safe example if you choose to dissent
badger God's made you so how is your
thought that you did that bad thing cuz
I didn't ask God to make me in a certain
way to make me do a bad thing yeah cuz I
cuz I don't understand how works the
freewill concept right right what makes
someone do something bad yeah I'm saying
right if God made us
then he's made us maybe do something you
know yeah
bizzy's was that your middle table
something he knows that he's assi yeah
yeah so before he made us he knew that
we were going to do this before making
in that way which we're going to okay
yeah so now there's we know I know I
exist
the echo says irrational of course you
know yeah yeah now there's going to be
things that you and I can understand
exactly cuz we can no grasp it there's
not me there is no reason behind it yeah
so for example we may agree that right
now yeah a tree fell in Amazon yeah did
you hear it no did you see it no did you
touch it no but does that mean that that
tree didn't fall
no okay so just because we don't grasp
it yeah
doesn't mean there's no wisdom behind
yeah so imagine your child is run into
the fire yeah and every time you reflux
along back yeah you keep your child yeah
your child flies yeah and they start
crying okay daddy
give me okay but what do they understand
they will run into the fire actually
save their life yeah but because of
their limited understanding that is
either yeah an off you same exact way
yeah like I know nobody can give an
answer
yeah man so another G yeah well let me
break it down for you now we know
otherwise the most trust yeah you know I
was all no again okay
Allah who never boys him or Hellfire
yeah unjustly because if one knows that
I'm gonna end up in the fire yeah and
he's crazy to me yeah and how is that
just exactly so therefore being unjust
goes against a lot yeah Nietzsche yeah
so let me ask you a question yeah yeah
you know eligible yeah yeah we really
yeah yeah you don't feel gate jail you
go to Bill Gates you say hm I want to
sell for business I want to be rich like
you
success - you go towards the streets
yeah and sell banana skins okay you did
it
Bill Gates Tommy - yeah go get strong
with you okay listen carefully if Bill
Gates told me to I'll do it yeah because
the gift ography is yeah what are you
telling me to do does it make sense
nope okay we do okay dr. zakir naik he
said this before so what is this year
Bill Gates is telling you to do
something that does not make sense to
you yeah but the reason you do it is
because the viewing is yes because you
have to work on trust there okay Allah
is telling you to do a lot of things
that make a lot of sense there but with
the matter of some things we don't
understand okay I was asking you like a
logical what would I get out unless it
is the most trust every single chapter
after and except once it's Allah the
most merciful - very much yeah so with
this matter we need to do is the
following yeah
I don't know you can imagine you have
two options if I'm gonna save one this
I'm not doing nothing
I'm not brain I'm probably going hell
yeah yeah I can see this oh I don't know
where I'm going
yeah so there'll be one person who see I
don't know where I'm going
therefore I'm not gonna do any righteous
TV doesn't matter God knows where I'm
going if I'm going to heaven I'm going
anywhere if I'm not going I'm going hell
yeah yeah another person who say I don't
know where I'm going but I don't go this
crazy this and giving me everything I'm
gonna be grateful so not how I should
receive the Prophet you know you go in
heaven why are you pretty shallow so
you're gonna go heaven why are you
praying to you next will ya so a person
with that mentality
do you believe somebody who's gonna
strive great do all of that Anna doesn't
even go no let me give you a he told us
now under their judgement a manual car
and he would tell all of us I want to go
Jenna yes with my good deeds okay well
how about this you say for example yeah
someone died God made it me this year
yes so God may have made some of us like
mentally like off yeah so say for
example like some people who follow
extremes of Islam but they actually
believe it yes the neighbor heaven okay
number even if they were if it wasn't
but they just misinformed and they
believe this comes back to they did it
because I want makes it clean the Koran
is something not to be nice to people
yeah so when he says no make you no
promises I'm gonna go and kill them yeah
is this Radisson I know
so this is for his own self because he
cannot blame God knows what she turned
it
Shaytan dreams I'm not yeah yeah unless
it last edition time
why did you know about a listen because
you misguided me yeah so we have Adam
yeah you have free time
yeah I've committed a sin yeah she sound
committed a sin yeah
one is doomed to hell yeah one is no
okay what's different between them two
number one know that Shaytan was a
righteous person okay he was so
righteous that he was he came to the
middle of angels yeah so and so it shows
you that even right there
so girl ask him to bow down to Adam yeah
his action or not bowing down did not
cause him to be damned to help to become
a Catholic a messaging or at least why
did you not bow in that moment of time
if you say
he said I am because you are
[Music]
so it shows you but it shows free will
he said so now the hadith I was telling
you about of the man who came under the
judgement
based on my shows he's gonna do okay
yeah I know if I do works no way
once you believe want to do righteous
deeds want to fast attention so in a
nutshell okay you know how much do you
know I was just thinking like if there's
a way to like maybe an analogy that you
could give the best thing to do is the
biggest yeah so why don't we all trust I
think good doctor luck likely said Bill
Gates exactly it's all none I begins
goes to it goes is because Bill Gates
gave you like if Bill Gates gave you a
hundred pound or something sorry you
said something about money money not the
one who gives it to you I don't know a
car mother fry anymore anyway yeah